So,
um,
yeah,
so MMA,
who named it mixed martial arts,
you know,
that's a look it,
that's a whole story.
And you're going to hear it was you.
Well,
I,
I give credit to Jeff Blatnick as far as looking at,
ah,
he didn't come up with the term who did,
but the truth that,
you know,
and this is the first thing I can tell you,
I wrote,
I wrote a,
uh,
I had to do it what's called a work permit for LAPD because I worked for LAPD
back in 1993,
93,
[inaudible] 94.
And it was because I was going to referee the second UFC,
which was March 11th in 1994.
And for me to actually work,
the department has to allow me to,
I have to ask for permission and then they have to grant that permission.
Was there a concern that it was too outrageous?
So that was part of the whole thing is I didn't want to say,
oh,
I got two guys going into a cage.
They're going to beat the shit out of each other.
So the first thing I put was martial arts.
Referee.
Okay.
And then they said,
well,
what kind of martial arts?
So I wrote mixed martial arts referee.
Now I can tell you that that was in 90 right at the end of 93 where did you get
out of term?
I didn't get it from anywhere other than I'm sitting there trying to think of,
but I do know that there was a columnist,
a sports writer from the La Times that wrote about the very first UFC and in his
article wrote mixed martial arts.
Ah,
so maybe it was him so,
well you got John Perretti,
he's saying that he's,
you know,
he did it back in 1983 and it's like,
okay,
well if no one's saying it,
it doesn't mean shit.
Right.
Okay.
So the truth of the matter is,
so Peretti might have said it in 83 it might've said it,
but it didn't mean anything because the fact of the matter is,
and it doesn't matter what I wrote,
what matters is when,
you know,
when you joined it,
when you joined the UFC,
it was still considered no holds barred.
NHB Yeah.
And it be was what we called and it was something that was,
and this is,
you know,
prob probably part of my problem with Campbell.
Mclaren is back at you before UFC too.
You know,
they had them on Good Morning America with Jim Brown and you go back to that and
he came up with the line that you could win by knockout,
tap out or death.
Okay.
And four years after that,
I was in court having that thrown in my face by the fricking attorney trying to
put us down and saying,
isn't this what you are companies?
No,
that's not what my committee says.
That's what an idiot said.
Okay.
And so he still to this day thinks he was magnificent with that.
But you look and you go,
might have been in terms of buying it drew attention,
paper view,
it drew attention.
There's no doubt.
But when we were trying to combat that,
we were trying to get away from no holds barred because no,
no holds barred met.
There's no rules.
And there was rules.